the President of the European Central
Bank arrives at a meeting of the
committee for economic affairs his job
today is to lay out the ECB strategy for
the next few years this is called
monetary dialogue lawmakers want to know
if EU monetary policies are on the right
track knowledge is power when voting any
piece can make their own decisions with
the correct information at hand the
pinas economic policies are more than
just monetary textile car manufacturing
construction these are only some of the
sectors which are sensitive to
globalization for majority of em eps
people working in those sectors deserve
to be protected among the tools of enos
disposal is the european globalization
funds for less skilled workers and those
more twists to get new jobs when a
factory shut down and the EU structural
funds that help people in rural areas
fisherman and poorer regions catch up
with the rest of the EU is essential it
works really good but it can be done
faster it can be done in a simple right
so the proposals now also from my side
go in the direction of less bureaucracy
the quicker spending and be more closer
to the people because of the financial
crisis of 2008 public investments in the
EU decreased considerably when that
happened Europe stepped in to invest in
jobs and growth but lawmakers want this
kind of investment to be simplified and
even more accessible they believe that
whenever EU funding works a new citizens
should be the first to know about it
[Music]